it's like when luke skywalker's dad died
so luke skywalker wound up having to
kill all those child jedi yes that's
exactly what wait is that what happened
i mean
a little
maybe a little
tom
which marvel characters do you think
will not survive phase four what a bleak
prospect
this is dark that's what we do
it's what we do here
so i feel like there are two obvious
answers here and they're both ant-man
right i feel like hank pym can't last
much longer no right
hank pym was on my short list
but he's he's the uh pun intended
brian thank you
bringing the fire i'm feeling a little
punchy feeling good a little punchy
a little punchy this is it
he's just riffing now go on
hank pym go on
i feel like he's gone from like kind of
jerk to the father figure a little bit
over the last few movies uh i don't feel
like older father figures necessarily do
too well in in in heroes journeys yeah i
i can't imagine that hank pym is going
to last too long
alternately
there's also
scott lang it was terrific we all love
scott lang but he does fit into a lot of
the categories that i think previously
murdered superheroes in the mcu fall
into where he's like mostly he's just
he's got
a younger girl version of him to take
over for him uh right out the back like
quicksilver
had had had scarlet witch ready to step
in as soon as he died and and black
widow died and then it turned out that
there was another florence pew black
widow
waiting for scott lang's uh you know
he's he's got his daughter cassie she's
ready to step in if you read the comics
uh right they did murder her pretty good
yes but i feel like they've been setting
up for her to her to kind of take over
the uh
right to fill the big shoes or small
shoes depending well they do get big
because she grows her superhero name is
stature so she's that's castle is one of
the um in the comics is one of the young
avengers along with
isaiah bradley's grandson
who we've seen in falcon in the winter
soldier along with the other hawkeye who
we'll see in hawkeye tv show played by
hayley steinfeld yes kate bishop wanda
maximoff's two kids billy and tommy
tommy tommy tommy i think billy and
willie that didn't
i don't know where you got that no no
um so they were um they were speed and
wiccan yes uh and then there was
kang had a uh a past self that came to
the
to the past from the future
as a kid as a hero named iron ladder so
now we've got kang as well and multiple
versions of kang running around and then
we've got hulkling who was a squad
so we've got skrulls all the pieces are
in the places yeah that we need for a
young event how are they not going to
dip into the young avengers well at some
point like
if they're they've got and i think
i think so i think they're they're
pretty clearly setting that up and then
in addition i think what you're
suggesting tom if you kill off scott
lang that's a pretty good motivator for
someone to be like well i'll take over
for my dad and do
what he couldn't or
you know same deal even if hank pym were
to go
you could have a similar kind of
inspiring
you know
now that now that papa pim is gone i'll
be the new papa pen right
but a lady pop up him it's like when
luke skywalker's dad died so luke
skywalker wound up having to kill all
those child jedi yes that's exactly what
wait is that what happened
i mean
a little
maybe a little he thought about it i
thought about it a second yeah
that's a pretty good watching different
rise of skywalkers yeah all right yeah
that was that was a good pick i think
that scott lang or hank pym
i think hank pam is a lot more likely
than scott lang gotta be right it's a
bummer but michael douglas is he's an
older he's an older guy and i don't
think he's gonna want to do that yeah
he wants to go hang out with catherine
zeta jones and live his life and for
that i respect him
i also want to do that to walk around
with like little dots painted yeah so
they can make you look like wall street
again yeah and we've also i mean with
the return of of the original wasp with
michelle pfeiffer showing up at the end
of
ant-man and the wasp now we've got that
character in there and you know again
from a storytelling perspective
if you have both of these elder
you know older heroes running around it
makes sense for one of them to go again
to provide motivation to the younger
heroes to go do heroic things and you
know the the balance needs to be
imbalanced right
you know what i mean so
i think that it makes some sense for for
that to happen that's a good pick plus
yeah you get to wrap up like a
redemptive arc for uh for hank he gets
to you know stop being a jerk and do the
whole ah i'm sorry that i did everything
right well and even though like hank's
more likely scott could also like
have that too right he could come full
circle as a dad and as a human and that
could be because like marvel does like
to
to you know cut the actor off when their
whole story arc is complete right
because then they're like what do we do
with you now
yeah and we don't want we don't want
paul rudd to be collecting too many
paychecks over this time period i
personally want him to he's gonna get
all the paychecks that he wants and
deserves he needs to find a new talk
show to show that mac and me footage on
he just needs to show up on conan's hbo
show and just show it for no reason
there you go yeah they'll just recreate
it yeah
makes sense to me nina what's your pick
so
it's funny i kind of went with the
similar idea uh to
you know someone can take over no one is
going to be surprised that i picked
hawkeye because i don't like him i don't
want to watch him anymore but i'm also
like you know kate bishop's right there
he's going to have this tv show
how much mileage can we really get out
of this guy yeah jeremy renner has music
to make things gotta happen
um he's gotta bring that app back yeah
he's gotta relaunch his app but
yeah so i do think i don't think you
know hawkeye's in this for the long haul
if they're setting him up with a young
avenger and that was kind of my exact
same thing as like kate bishop will want
to avenge him
in the same way that elena wants to
avenge her sister
if elena kills him like
that would be kind of cool
it's it's
it's but also like he's getting a whole
series with his name on it so it's
probably not going to happen yeah it
seems unlikely
but the fact that they are adding a
second character who goes by hawkeye to
the show yeah that's what i'm saying so
and it's and the second hawkeye is
played by academy award nominee haley
steinfeld you know so
well isn't the first hawkeye played by
academy award nominee jeremy renner shh
she's younger it's more impressive
i'm just saying if you're going to bring
in the bonus you've got no i think what
i'm saying is like they didn't bring in
some like newcomer like they brought in
someone you know very very famous that's
true
that's true i thought you were saying
haley steinfeld was just straight up a
more legit actor well jeremy rooney no
i'm not saying that
um but i do have like
there's also this the cynical logical
part of me that feels like
um aside from hawkeye it'll be julie lou
dreyfuss contessa because how long does
that woman really want to stay in the
mcu
well yeah i mean i think that she's
gonna clear well yeah she's set up for a
while she is but it's also like if if
that woman with all of her arm loads of
emmys was like i don't want to do this
anymore
she could get herself written off in
dramatic fashion
if need be i
i mean she's clearly being set up to be
a villain right she's clearly being set
up to be kind of the anti-nick fury
right will she go at the end of phase
four phase four is a long that's what
i'm saying two years right so it's
possible that at the end of this phase
at whatever you know big showdown her
character right is building these this
anti-avengers for maybe she'll bite the
dust
i
i think she'll last a little bit longer
you think she'll move in the back and it
went into a subsequent phase i think
that she could because again like what
is she being asked to do she's not
getting strapped to any ridge true right
she doesn't have to fly around she
doesn't have to sit through and get like
a bunch of makeup slathered on yeah she
puts on cool sunglasses and a purple
streak in her hair yeah and she's just
like she just makes jokes and that's it
right she's basically just doing sitcoms
stuff and making marvel money so
that's a fair point but i also i'm just
like one if i were julia lee dreyfus i
think i'd be like i want to do a couple
of these macs
but
yeah but i could be wrong and i don't
want her to get killed off i am thrilled
anytime i see julia dreyfus do literally
anything i could i would watch a movie
of her just sitting in a chair for like
six hours because it would probably be
really funny
yeah but
yeah i'd enjoy it but no i don't want
her to get killed off but i'm also like
i'm very cynical about how actors make
decisions about their lives and their
livelihoods and it's not like yeah and
also she has seinfeld money this is not
about checks for this woman yeah that's
true she can she can ride her own yeah
she's fine yeah
yeah
she's
not hurting
i had a list of names that i came up
with
um i had a few and i have one ultimate
pick but i'm just gonna run through a
few okay one is uh roadie war machine oh
armor wars yeah
right rough
right he's been around since iron man
one he's like the old guard yeah
the character's been around since the
very beginning yeah so it's it strikes
me as a as a fitting end to armor wars
if he goes out in a blaze of glory
especially since we're gonna have iron
heart coming through in the black
panther sequel soon
um
so i see that as a potential exit and
again he's been doing this for a while
and each project that they do they
command a higher and higher paycheck
right eventually they may just be like
yeah don cheadle we're done like
you can go do some other prestige
television same deal with nick fury nick
fury's been around since the beginning
samuel jackson is
getting older how much longer does he
want to do this i actually i thought
about him and then i was also like i
feel like he just wants to do this
forever
no there's that yeah i mean again he's
not they're not putting him no they
don't have to do he just gets to show up
with an eye patch and be cool every now
and then like it's not yeah yeah
so he's yeah so he's doing good
um another one i thought of was drax the
destroyer ooh
you think they're going to kill drax
i think they could because guardians of
the galaxy 3 is going to be in phase 4.
we know that dave bautista is not super
thrilled with the disney machine right
like yeah recently at the time of this
recording they someone asked him on
twitter like hey why didn't you do the
voice of drax on the second episode of
what if he was just like how about
because they didn't ask me right and
caused this like mini controversy or
everyone's just like
you know we did ask you we asked your
agent and then like the agents are like
you never asked us he's also getting a
little way more popular like
everyone's casting him in everything i
would say largely thanks to guardians
like he's having his like and i would
yeah he's like john cena phase of his
career for sure and i would bet that the
the nature of his contract was probably
not super good because when he first
signed it yeah the first guardians of
the galaxy was his first major role out
of you know being a wrestler yeah now
he's in knives out too like a huge leap
yeah
so he's probably ready to be done i'm
not in the cast of knives out too
somehow none of us are don't know that
that's true i'm actually
sorry
please put that in bryce i was going to
say that for brian's uh name
appearing in knives out too
appearing in knives out too
so that so that's one thought so i think
a a a a big way to end guardians of the
galaxy 3 would you know a big death
right we had yondu at the end of the
second one i don't think that they're
going to kill off chris pratt's
character yeah they're they're already
working on
gamora's already been brought back to
life so it doesn't make sense that
either of that couple would get killed
off but i do think that drax feels like
he has a bit of a target on him
especially because he's also gone on
record of saying he doesn't like like
all the makeup applications i think he's
done with it sure i think he's done so
that's my prediction but that's actually
not the character i was going to talk
about
which is
jane foster in thor love and thunder oh
i think that she
they brought natalie portman back to do
this one movie wow okay that's to be the
protagonist it's gonna be the reunion of
jane foster and thor odin's son they're
gonna reunite that's the love
but we also know that from the comics
she became thor while she was also
undergoing treatment for cancer and that
was tied in with her power where she was
getting chemotherapy but every time she
turned into thor it would purge her body
of toxins and so the chemotherapy didn't
work
and so a common medical ailment yeah
right it just it happens to the best of
us so at the end of that comic story
line she dies now because this is comics
she's brought back to life she gets
chemotherapy and she's okay but she
doesn't have powers anymore but i think
this is a taika ytt movie this is a guy
who's really good at blending super
duper dramatic emotional stuff with
wacky goofy stuff right like if anyone
remembers you know
scarlett johansson's shoes and jojo i
was just going to bring that up oh that
was
hunt for the wilder yeah yeah that's
some heavy duty stuff yeah really fun
funny movie right but it's like serious
stuff yeah even thor ragnarok has some
pretty you know emotional stuff where uh
odin dies that's not necessarily the big
cry moment um
it's it's much more subdued in that one
it's much more of a fun comedy that
movie but i think taika waititi now that
he's confident now that they're just
like trusting him to do whatever he
wants they've brought
uh they've brought natalie portman back
they convinced her i think they said hey
do this one movie the star of the movie
you're gonna have a really dramatic
death
and everyone will
cry after they saw you kick a bunch of
ass in the movie fighting like thor
fighting as thor
and then at the end you get to die in
this tragic dramatic way
man what a what a legendary way to go
out after leaving a franchise you
weren't really that into for the first
two movies that's my pick that's mine
that's
that's really talking about that's
really good uh because that would be the
perfect way to get a movie star like
natalie portman to come back to a
franchise she famously hated to be like
it's just the one movie because the
whole time i was like oh she's coming
back cause it's stuck away tt and he is
an oscar and like everyone loves him and
i mean i'm guessing people are lining up
to work with him i
i would if i were an actor but like
i just want to work with him now i just
want to hang out like while he writes
and be like what are you doing what are
you doing what are you writing um
what is it now yeah what scene is it
this is all after knives out two comes
in
no but that's a good point that maybe
they were like hey you only have to do
one thing
uh we're not gonna pin you two because
i mean
it it has to be one thing or the other
with her right like either she dies or
she like takes the mantle from chris
hemsworth i would think
i mean it's that's entirely possible too
because chris hemsworth's been doing
this for yeah but from what i understand
in my limited role as guy on the
internet uh he seems to really love
doing thor yeah he's playing knives
yeah i'm playing guy on the internet
i'm just doing this
i'm just typing don't spoil it for us
god
i don't want to know anything
but yeah i think chris hemsworth really
likes doing this and so i think having
natalie portman come in it doesn't make
sense that she's going to take over a
franchise yeah i'd love it if she did i
think it would be really fun but it just
doesn't
seem like the kind of thing
prestige actor
natalie portman would do it's tricky
because i one and done situation i agree
but she also hasn't been like doing a
ton of stuff lately that's true yeah
this might be the comeback that she was
waiting for come back like yeah she's
natalie
she's just ever present yeah
yeah
so yeah those are my picks that's what i
think will happen so we'll come back in
a few years
uh assuming that we're still doing this
a few years from now at the end of phase
four and we'll see which one of us was
right and which one of us was wrong i
bet all of us were right we're all right
i'll still be doing this
knives out to
something something boogaloo
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
episode